Your task was to explore the relationship between friends initiated
and age. For the ggplot syntax, we're just going to pass it,
x, which will be age, and y, which will be friends
initiated. We'll put those in the aesthetic wrapper and then pass
pf, as our data frame. I also need to remember to
specify the geom, so here I'll use geom point for a
scatter plot. This should get me going. It looks like that
I used the wrong variable here, so looking at my data
I can see that friendships initiated should be my variable,
rather than friends initiated. Running this code, we can see
our scatter plot. Now, I still get this discreteness with
age, so I'm going to jitter our points. Here, I'll use an
alpha set to one tenth, so I'll need ten points
to make just one of these. That's looking a little bit
better. Another way to jitter the points is to still
use geom_point. But then to set the position equal to jitter.
This code will produce the same plot that we have here. Let's
run it to be sure. Sure enough, we have the same plot.
And since I still have really high values for some of my
friendships initiated, I'm going to use a cord transformation and take the
square root of the y axis. When I add the cord trans-layer
and run this code I see that I get an error message.
This should make sense since some of my friendships initiated have a
count of zero. So, when I take the square root of that number
with some noise, it might be negative which would be
an imaginary result. So, I'm going to fix this code like we
had before, so that way we have the positions set equal
to h equals 0. So, we'll set position equal to position
jitter and we'll pass it h equals 0. This is
the plot that I came up with. Now, you might have
had something slightly different, or you might have even used a
different transformation. Whatever you found,
and whatever your observations may be,
share them in the discussions. We'd love to hear from you.